welcome back good to see everybody
thank you all for coming this place see
the interest is still there is it your
intention to always tell the truth from
that podium and will you pledge never to
knowingly say something that is not that
it is it's an honor to do this and yes I
believe that we have to be honest with
the American people I think sometimes we
can disagree with the facts photographs
of the inaugural proceedings were
intentionally framed in a way in one
particular tweet to minimize the
enormous support that had gathered on
the National Mall this was the largest
audience to ever witness an inauguration
period and then obviously there's been
discussion of Paul Manafort who played a
very limited role for a very limited
amount of time but beyond that general
Dagon Jonathan hunt can you can you stop
interrupting other people in questions
okay Jonathan somebody's asking a
question it's not your press briefing
Julie's asking a question please calm
down I mean just yesterday he sat down
with Martin Luther King jr. I would call
him a civil rights leader when his dad
was the bird well I read safe because at
the end of the day let me in i am i okay
we don't what you're asking me a
question and I'm going to answer which
is the president I'm sorry please stop
shaking your head again happy
Valentine's Day I can sense the love in
the room at some point April you're
going to have to take no for an answer
with respect to whether or not there was
collusion
here we go okay that's a read it you
basically okay Kristin we're going to
end this right onto our contr contract
no I get my point is that you can go
through a nitpick and say okay well this
individual is but that's why we slow it
down a little and to make sure that if
they are a five-year-old that maybe
they're there with their parents and
there they don't pose a threat but to
assume that just because of someone's
age or gender or whatever that they
don't pose a threat would be misguided
and wrong for all of the people who have
concerns about this especially on the
right look at the size this is the
Democrats this is up there is I mean
that you can't get any clearer in terms
of this is government this is not know
and then this one is the aggressive 13
here as well or the 2017 it is literally
100% the same you know someone as
despicable as Hitler who didn't even
think to the to the - using chemical
weapons there was no he was not using
the gas on his own people the same way
that a shot is doing it mean there was
clearly I Michael II I mistakenly used
an inappropriate and insensitive
reference to the Holocaust for which
frankly there is no there is no no no
comparison and for that I apologize it
was a mistake to do that well first of
all it's not a travel do you think
that's the words that the media is using
at the end of the day it can't well I
know but it can't be a campaigner
himself responded I understand what
confuse or you know I'm not confused
good afternoon I hope everyone had a
great weekend seriously the president
used the word wiretap in quotes to mean
broadly surveillance and other
activities his tweets do speak for
themselves
so you just sort of interpreted it for
Peters and well he didn't mean at
present
that's not what I said no no actually
they when he when he said when he met
wiretapping right that it he meant
surveillance literally had it in quotes
the president has already said clearly
when he referred to wiretapping he was
referring to surveillance so that's why
but it sounds like Sean okay you and the
president are saying now well we don't
need wiretapping anyone know if that's
not true we know that we're going no no
that's not your forms are so
what's it going to be that no no okay
can you say a furtive ly that whenever
the president said something we can
trust it to be read if he's not joking
of course
let me put the net cakes hold on quick
but no no good afternoon
I want to thank my colleague Sarah for
sitting in on Friday she's a great job I
missed you all tremendously so instead
of approaching reporters after he did a
segment on Fox Business he decided to
hide in the bushes
rather than face all of the reporters
standing there waiting to ask him about
James Comey being fired do you think
people should be concerned on the
president is posted somewhat of an
incoherent tweet last night and the
defense stayed up for hours no why did
it stay up so long there's no one
watching us now I think that the
president and a small group of people
know exactly what a man like would be
like well you guys just the email where
that wall is from exactly so we can
identify the location for Sean it's
right on top
Charmian on where younger way